reading is powerful and how it forms our
brain how it helps us acquire new
languages hi there steve kaufman here
again and today i want to talk about
reading because the last time i spoke
about listening
remember though if you enjoy my videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications if you follow me on a
podcast service
please leave a comment
so
i spoke about listening and how powerful
it is podcast service you know so many
ways that we can listen today
how throughout the history of time
uh listening has been a major way for
the major way
whereby people learned learned from
others were entertained acquired
knowledge communicated listening was the
key
reading is relatively recent
i don't know i don't remember exactly
when you know people first started
writing we have
chinese turtle shell script if i
remember correctly from my chinese
history
we have uniform the scripts you know in
in old elam and sumer and akkad and
mesopotamia again my
knowledge of history is fuzzy fuzzy
knowledge is good until you have to
write exams because you're gradually
getting a clearer and clearer picture of
these things and and even when you think
you've firmed up you know you remember
the actual you know date of
the
ruler of whatever in ancient something
or other
pretty soon you forget it so it doesn't
matter so vaguely
i think the first writing took place
somewhere in the fertile crescent
uh and i think the original you know
purpose of writing was to keep track of
you know for accounting purposes keeping
track of the grain that was in storage
and it helped to administer things and
then there is the famous
um
darius's
declaration of human rights which was
written using a cuneiform
script and i believe it was written in
not in persian but in in the language of
of elam or i just don't remember as i
say my history knowledge is very fuzzy
but i have a vague
and the vague i always feel by the way
this gets me to reading
you know
whenever we're told to read in school
we're asked questions about our
understanding and i always resist these
listening comprehension questions or
reading comprehension questions
i like having an imperfect knowledge of
what i read if i enjoyed what i read if
i found it interesting if i understood
many parts of it but didn't understand
some other parts and i can't remember
the exact date of this or who did what
to whom
it doesn't matter it was still enjoyable
to me i like reading for enjoyment
but
starting back whenever it was 2500 3000
years ago when the first people started
writing for whatever purpose
uh up until basically
the popularization of of um you know
printing in the 15th century
and even thereafter most people didn't
read so the brain
which is you know from an evolutionary
perspective has had a lot of experience
at listening and deciphering meaning
from listening
hasn't had very much experience or
exposure
at
dealing with
writing and it's quite amazing to me
that you can have lines on a piece of
paper
uh whatever the script may be it doesn't
matter whether it's the latin script or
whether it's chinese characters or
whether it's the
you know persian script or hangul it
doesn't matter you've got lines that are
converted by the brain into meaning
sometimes also
in most cases in fact converted into
sound so the brain has to do this
processing which which is a tremendous
feat for the brain to do because it was
something that the brain was not
you know
prepared to do
over the hundreds of thousands of years
that that human beings and their
predecessors have been wandering around
on the earth
and
so i enjoy reading
uh
you know right now i'm reading a german
book
a german book about the austro-hungarian
empire which is where my parents were
born actually
and to sit in bed with a book
even if i'm reading on my ipad which i
like to do because i can look up the odd
word in german that i don't know
uh
it's cozy i don't want the sound i don't
want the audio i just want
the written word to connect with that
written word because the written word
conjures up the meaning in a different
way from listening i mean in a way the
written
text is a record it's a record just as
the audio is a record but it's a
different kind of record and i'm not a
neuroscientist so i don't know whether
different parts of the brain process the
writing as opposed to the audio to
convert them into meaning but i am
convinced that doing a lot of reading as
well as listening
helps in acquiring languages i've said
before that
if i just hear the sound of a new
language i can almost not make out the
sound but if i get a phonetic
version of that and in the case of a
non-phonetic script like chinese
characters i'll i would use the pinyin
but it helps to define that sound and
gradually i get better at hearing that
sound but i rely on the written script
in order to decipher the sound
and i i think this is true of everyone
and we see how people very often
are influenced in how they pronounce a
word in another script
if the say say using the latin alphabet
if someone is say check
and they read something in english
or if they're a spanish speaker and they
read something in english they will be
influenced by how what the letters mean
how they are pronounced in their native
language and that'll be reflected in how
they pronounce the new language so
they're obviously not relying entirely
on hearing the sound they are very much
influenced by
their habits
you know their reading habits and what
the value of the of those letters are in
their own writing system
so reading is powerful and how it forms
our brain how it helps us acquire new
languages
and
it's pleasant it's a different
experience i can sit with a book and
read for two three hours
i can't sit just sit and listen for two
three hours i lose concentration i get
restless if i'm in my car listening
that's fine and the great advantage of
listening of course is that it's so
portable you can be doing other things
while listening you can sort of fade in
and out while listening because you're
also doing something else you're kind of
happy whereas when you're reading
if you fade out you kind of have to
reread the sentence again because you're
kind of more focused at least that's my
own experience more focused on the
meaning when you're reading and so
reading
other than the fact that it's
the fastest way to acquire and acquire
information if i if i need uh
instructions on how to fix my coffee
maker or something like or if i look up
something on the internet
having to do with i don't know
recharging my
iphone
i prefer to read because it's faster i
can select i can jump from spot to spot
i can i can get that information more
quickly if i have to listen or watch
through a video
then i'm kind of at the mercy of whoever
is speaking or
producing the video whereas if i'm
reading i control where i go
similarly with a book if i want to skip
this chapter or jump ahead or behind and
i know exactly where i want to go to i
can skim the pages and see those areas
that are of interest to me so reading is
is quite a different
experience but reading
is powerful i've said before
i consider with a new language when i
have read a whole book
paper book without a dictionary without
the ipad from cover to cover i consider
that to be a major milestone i'm far
from being able to do that in persian or
arabic because i'm not comfortable
enough with the script but
even in polish which i don't speak well
at all i can make my way through a book
i know enough words and of course the
writing system is familiar to me so uh
an obstacle when we're learning
languages where the writing system is
different
is that you can't make up for in my case
uh 70 plus years of reading in the latin
script and expect that a couple of years
of reading in the in the arabic script
is going to give me the same degree of
familiarity with that script and yet i
know that if i if i want to progress
in persian or arabic i have to get
better at reading reading is a major
you know again source of enjoyment but
also a major learning activity and some
people say they don't like to read
all i can say is try to develop the
habit start reading
things of real interest to you obviously
don't take on a classic of you know
french literature if that's not of
interest to you read the
comics read the things on sports
that's i think where anime in the case
of
people interested in japanese is kind of
like cartoons read comic books
whatever you like to read develop that
reading habit
get the brain used to reading used to
converting meaning from
written text because it's going to be a
major major advantage
in life
professionally academically whatever but
also in terms of language learning it's
it's a powerful powerful activity so as
you know i'm very much in favor of
input-based learning build up your
potential through reading and listening
and when you have the opportunity to
speak speak but don't neglect reading
it's powerful
anyway
i've done videos on the subject before
so i'll leave a few here for reference
for you thank you for listening bye for
now